I think it's time to get together let's
have a look at these and see if we can
make some sense out of them start at the
top this is about as straight a
derivative as you could be given at this
point yes I know there's a few twists
and turns in there but not too many
because all you need to do is use your
power rule and use it twice so what do
you reckon sonam's derivative over there
15 X to the 4 minus 2x on 3 are you
happy with that yes no yes I know hmm
let's have a look how did we get to this
answer well let's start with the first
15 X so therefore where's that 15 from
where'd you get that from yeah very good
so what we've done is we've taken this
power and we've said first very first
thing we're going to bring that out the
front 5 times 3 it's 15 fantastic and
then we will subtract 1 from the power
are we ok with that so far it's good
thumbs up all right let's have a look at
this guy now let's try and rehearse that
same process we've got this power of 2
instead of 5 so when a multiplet at the
front would I get I've got I've got that
to this thumbs up okay and then what was
the next thing I was supposed to do I'm
going hold on a second have I multiplied
by the coefficient twos come out the
front there it is right there and then I
reduce the power by one so what should I
have over here it was X to the two
before now it's extra do you agree with
that apart from me having accidentally
deleted part of saddam's life with that
on three come from what's that doing
there where did that come from it came
from right here right over here just
like in this case this 3 just kind of
hung on for the ride it's what happens
with these constant coefficients we can
forget about them for a brief moment as
we differentiate but then they don't
disappear still they're right same deal
with this division by 3 are you happy we
can fit ourselves
actually used to call it coefficient
great questions so when we have a look
at this x squared on three right it
doesn't look like it's set up for a
coefficient right now because we would
tend to write coefficients at the front
however can we write x squared on three
as if it were just a coefficient how
would we rewrite it yeah okay
one-third right that's divided by three
is the same as multiplying by 1/3 and
then the x squared is Holmes's so really
it might be dressed up differently but
same deal those up yeah all right let's
have a look at this one it takes a bit
of work to get to this point but can
someone give me before we check this out
the previous slide will actually several
previous lines when we're just doing the
product rule right you're gonna call
this you gonna call it V I suppose you
could switch the order doesn't matter
what's your first slide that we should
all have written down everyone should
have pretty much the same first line in
order recite it for me okay you can just
go straight to going from the product
rule out of this which in this case I'll
do it up here what is that in this case
this is actually excuse me the case they
are looking for here what am I gonna
write down it's gonna be a long gross
expanded theme that's fine yep good
someone helped now what's you - okay
great someone else take over I've got a
plus who do you take over
rotary reckon you can handle from you
can you can you tell me why next part
here I very what half a line you wanna
rescue us go ahead you had your hand up
X cube minus one don't forget the
brackets and what do you reckon hope
grace I'm getting some nods yep
thumbs up okay now we could we could go
through this next process right and
hopefully get from here to here I'm not
that worried about that part because
this is something which number one we're
not focusing on number two is something
which ought to be able to do a little
bit on autopilot the main thing I want
to see was could you differentiate which
lands you here okay last one now no one
came up the front to get to an answer
for this one partly because it's the
last one so can we do this one together
what's gonna be our first step
go ahead straight starts off yep go
ahead I'm gonna write that very good
okay fantastic what are the great things
about the question rule is it is a
question so that's one of the easy ways
to trigger remembering which one is
which let's quickly have a go here if we
say this is U and this is V make sure
you use in visa written very differently
by the way because in this case it does
matter which one switch let's have a go
V in this case
Leslie helps out very good
Oh shun you can take over what's the
next thing go to write you could look up
here it's okay yeah yeah it's one by the
way that doesn't change what this is
going to be equal to right when you
multiply by something by one doesn't
change do you think it matters that I
put that one there hmm
in a sense it doesn't because as we just
said when you multiply something by one
doesn't change but I really like having
that one there it shows me when I read
you're working it shows me that you'd
know what you're doing because you've
actually differentiated something as
you're doing the question rule okay next
step where we're gonna go thank you
and then I'm even gonna be generous and
give you V dash because I'm nice like
that okay there's our numerator and then
what's on the denominator X plus one all
squared now I could write that as x
squared plus 2x plus 1 there's not
really much point is there because it's
not like you can cancel extra stuff out
once you've got that let's just tidy
this up because it's so very easy to do
you've got an X plus 1 here and an X
minus 1 here so what are you gonna be
left with once you collect your like
terms what happens to the x's ya X take
away X so they're gone
you've got a one take away a negative
one so what happens that two
take away negative one yeah thanks we're
all awake good tonight all right are you
happy with that